and it's really a cocktail of all the
cars I've ever loved
exotic cars like the old-school Ferrari
288 GTO s and the Lamborghinis but it's
also very American it has a lot of
Corvette Dodge Viper 4 GT the entire car
weighs about twenty eight hundred and
fifty pounds every body panel on the car
is carbon fiber the standard engine is
620 horsepower there's also an optional
1,100 horsepower car 395,000 for a twin
turbo car of this nature you're getting
so much car for the money we're building
a brand and when that brand has the
strength to charge the larger numbers a
million dollars plus you know you
probably see us up there as well
the falcon owner is somebody who has
sort of been there done that
and they want something much more
exclusive they want the ultimate car
they want something that is unusual and
different they're set up for each
individual customer some guys want to be
on the racetrack all the time or we can
set it up for the guy who likes to just
drive around in a great GT car the red
car behind us was purchased by a
gentleman's wife and one of the
requirements was that car was painted
the color off her favorite purse
purchasing a car from us is a very
intimate experience especially for the
people that have bought one locally
they're in here all the time watching
their cars be built about 95% of this
car is built in Michigan means a lot to
the customers that it comes out of
Detroit I mean that was a stronger
aspects to the company than I imagined
from the beginning but people resonate
with that a lot of engineers and experts
in the Detroit area donated their time
and their expertise to make sure that
this car was going to be a great car